With us.
I don't think we,
most military don't look at it that way.
We don't calculate that.
I might not come home.
That's,
that's like a factor that's never
calculated it into our decision making
process.
Our biggest thing is we might let the
guy down next to us.
So for us it's our training,
um,
to kind of go over there and execute our
mission.
That's our biggest thing in the marine
corps.
Pushes that mission,
accomplishment,
mission accomplishment and troop
welfare.
And I think with that mindset we go in,
we're already pretty prepared for what's
going to go on,
you know,
for,
for me engaging the enemy or anything,
I always kind of thought I was doing
what I was trained to do and I kind of
separated emotion from it.
And,
and I've,
I've gotten better at it over the years.
Every deployment I went back,
I understood that in motion.
His only weakness over here for me,
I must think objectively.
I don't,
a general maddis always says a phrase,
no better friend,
no worse enemy.
And I think it's like the best thing
because really it's,
it kind of explains what the fighting
man has to kind of do over there.
But it's very hard.
It's hard to go over there without
emotion.
It's,
you know,
after one of your friends gets hit by a
roadside bomb,
it's hard not to be pissed,
but the truth is you got to realize,
hey,
this is the nature of the beast.
I got to drive on.
I'm not going to take it out on other
Iraqis that aren't involved,
you know.
Um,
I got hit by a rocket pro grenade and
April seven,
2004,
nine and the initial push into Falucia,
um,
for me,
we got,
we got slammed right going into an
ambush and,
uh,
we were the point vehicle.
It actually,
well,
I blew off my assistant team leader at
both his hands,
Eddie,
right?
Um,
it broke my arm,
blew up my trigger finger and did a it
wounded everyone else in my vehicle.
Uh,
what we did,
we pushed out of the kill zone and
actually got stuck in a secondary kill
zone,
uh,
where we were surrounded by about 26
guys.
And,
uh,
we had to do medical aid to ourselves,
but I put a tourniquet on and uh,
one of my young Lance Corporal Lance
Corporal Meson actually tourniqueted um,
up Eddie.
But uh,
for us it was actually kind of funny
cause this is like that Marine Corps
humor that you see throughout the
series.
And he writes in the backseat cracking
jokes and the guy has no hands.
And uh,
for me it's like calm breeds calm.
So I'm like,
Shit,
if this guy is laughing about this,
you know,
how can I be worried?
I'm definitely not as bad as he is.
And he actually made a bad situation
kind of somewhat entertaining.
And then we just went back and we just
executed what we trained for cause and
high,
high levels of stress.
You always resort back to your last
highest level of training.
For me,
this is my third combat tour.
So it wasn't like I was worried.
I just,
I just kind of,
everything was muscle memory.
I did whatever we had to do to survive
it.
We got back out of the kill zone and,
uh,
probably about an hour and a half,
two hours later we were metal backed out
of there.
I always kind of promised that I was
gonna I was gonna make things right for
Eddie.
I just Kinda,
you know,
after seeing him in the hospital that
actually brought me to tears to him in
Icu.
It's hard.
I don't,
you know,
it's hard to say.
I don't want to say I wanted to go kill
a bunch of people to get back,
you know,
revenge because you know,
then again,
that's kind of,
you know,
using my emotion part.
But I wanted to,
I wanted to make it feel like that we
were wounded that day for something.
You know,
it wasn't for nothing.
I wanted to get back there and,
and try and fix the problems Iraq had.
And if that meant fight him and fight if
that man fix the infrastructure or
worked with the local Iraqis,
do whatever I can,
whatever's in my power to make that
place better.
And I,
I learned a lot because my fourth and
fifth tours are totally different than
what you see in generation kill.
Um,
a lot of what I did is actually live
with the Iraqis,
um,
now to 24 man platoon and we,
we created kind of an atmosphere where
they can be safe or they're around.
We learned off them,
we learned everything from how to cook.
Uh,
there,
there were flatbread are Hovis to how to
hook up a Italian porn on their tvs to
teaching them how to patrol.
Um,
you know,
and,
and working with these people closely
and try and get rid of everything from
the criminal annulment.
That's,
that's like running loose in Iraq to
work with the terrorist and uh,
the other elements that are there cause
it's very complex and I learned so much
more in my,
my fourth and fifth tour then you then I
could ever imagine,
I mean I kind of look back at my first
multiple tours and it's like,
wow,
if I knew what I knew now,
you know,
we could have done such a better job
back then.
We did it on this place called pork chop
island is like a,
I think in the history of the world.
I don't think anyone's been injured on
that island.
But,
uh,
for me it's like getting back on the
horse and I was actually paranoid and
actually kind of how well it must be.
What captain America fell in.
Oh,
I have one.
I was very paranoid because I was
calculating and everything,
every comment I've seen in the past,
like possible ambushes that can go down
and everything.
And my mind was just racing and,
uh,
and I was like,
man,
why,
why did I come back here?
And,
um,
I think after I got over it,
it was just like one day of extreme
paranoia for some reason.
But,
uh,
after that,
I went back to just push an emotion to
the side and doing my job.
And I had no.